currently in quite a strange theater we
call it theater but it deserves many
different purposes it's a kind of holy
place it's a it's a really special place
you know when you walk in that that you
are in somewhere that is slightly
different there are there are paintings
on the walls there are colors there are
there are lights that shine differently
than than anywhere else in the jungle
this space served upon all nationalities
all genders there's no judgment it is
completely open you can sip some draw
right the torque you can share you can
sing you can dance
David ohm arrived they all got involved
in building it I mean important thing to
point as it doesn't belong to us we just
made it happen people here built it that
people here have had as much input as we
have in in creating the program they
come and they say you know I should I
want to teach kung fu because I'm a
black belt in Taekwondo and confu so
that's great we have that you know twice
a week now
what happens in there is special 50
nationalities come together and sing and
respect each other's music or dance war
or writing or stories
place is a celebration of the human
beings who found themselves there
you